[Music]
whether it's revamping an old space or
bringing a classic floor back to life
watch as three professionals tackle age
neglect and misuse that have produced
some of the dirtiest and stickiest flaws
Kate dear the CEO of fatwell walks us
through how she deep cleans a bank floor
made in 1908 it hasn't been touched in
seven years and she's revamping the
space into a wedding venue she found the
tile under the carpet during an asbestos
inspection and decided to deep clean it
so it could be part of the new space the
carpet is very thick and therefore heavy
so the first thing she does is get the
carpet off and let the tile breathe the
carpet glue was the thickest she'd ever
encountered and completely covered the
tile underneath the moisture and heat
from the steam are some of the only
things that would seep through the glue
to loosen it
after she hits it with the steamer she
scrapes it up and starts sanding the top
layer where the glue stains the tile
with a yellow Haze
she adds Zep floor stripper which
liquefies the glue so she's able to
scrape it up with a blade
foreign of the carpet glue become really
tough to remove she puts down a marble
polish to help buff out those sections
the floor is old and uneven so her team
needs to use a bristle brush attachment
to get the steam in
then the team seals the tile to protect
it for the future
[Music]
the owner of Pinnacle Stone Restoration
walks us through how his team deep
cleans terrazzo floors that are over 100
years old
parts of the terrazzo floors were hidden
under carpet and discovered as the room
was being renovated
the most difficult part of this clean is
carpet and glue removal
he removes the carpets with electric
scraping machines and the carpet glue
with handheld scrapers
Costa removes the glue by hand because
it keeps the temperature low which helps
the glue come out more easily from the
terrazzo
grinding the terrazzo floors helps to
flatten and even out the surface
then he moves onto the honing process
which cleans and polishes off the
scratch is left behind by the grinding
process he starts polishing using a 1
500 grit Diamond pad followed by 3000
Grit
after that he uses another system that
has much finer pads which make the
terrazzo harder and more durable
then it's time to seal
Costa uses a sealer that seeps into the
terrazzo and protects it from stains
burnishing the floors helps the sealer
bring the terrazzo to its highest Sheen
[Music]
Courtney Lee and his team at Truman's
hardwood floor refinishing tackle dark
muddy looking floors
they're covered with thick wax layers
resulting from DIY attempts at
revitalizing Wood Floors
the acrylic waxes from products that are
meant for short-term Solutions are
extremely soft and don't harden up or
cure
they sit on top of the floors instead of
soaking in allowing dirt soil and any
Airborne contaminants to bond to them
Courtney's team of floor technicians
specializes in wax removal from hardwood
floors
floor refinishing requires sanding off
existing Coatings but it's difficult to
do with these layers of wax sitting on
top because the wax will likely clog up
the Sanders
the team comes in to emulsify the wax
which takes it back to a liquid form and
allows them to extract it from the
floors
build up like this usually happens over
the course of five to twenty years
they spray the floors with an emulsifier
and let it sit for some time depending
on the severity and amount of wax they
do this section by section they follow
up with extraction tools which remove
the wax from the floors into the machine
depending on how much wax there is they
repeat this two to three times
the buffer runs at a low speed during
this process there is a soft pad and a
mesh screen on the bottom which comes in
different grids the screen scratches off
the old polyurethane so the team can
apply new polyurethane
this is what SEALs and protects the
hardwood floors and is typically the
final layer before the wax a splash
guard is usually attached to the buffer
to keep the wax from slinging onto the
walls and baseboards
in some cases like here corny will
scrape off the wax by hand
he does this when there is too much
buildup on the floor
he'll scrape up as much as possible to
prevent the wax from clogging up the
Vacuums in their machines
and then remove the residual as normal
once Courtney removes the wax the floor
is back to its bare original state
in some cases depending on what the
homeowners want to do he'll apply a new
layer of polyurethane to finish the job
[Music]